[Music]
the countdown is on for their big day
these soon-to-be married couples in
bristol are busy planning their future
but like all of us they're worried about
the road ahead and want the new prime
minister to ease the current pressure
what's your number one thing that you
would like the new premises to sort out
pretty much helping out people who are
not the lowest paid income but also not
the highest we're kind of in the middle
so we get no help at all and our energy
bills have just jumped by
130 pounds a month without telling us i
think we're looking to start a family so
we'd be after an adequately funded nhs
energy prices that needs to be taken
care of
worries at the wedding fair are echoed
on the streets on the other side of
bristol kevin is working overtime he's
been keeping this city clean for the
last 19 years what
would you want the new prime minister to
do what's top of your list that you want
them to do
basically to
sort out about the gas and the electric
extremely worried um i mean i've got to
work six days a week just to
try and survive you know in less than a
month households here and across the
country could see their energy bills
rise by 80 percent
little wonder that for families it's
also their main concern energy prices
are rising the housing rate is rising so
for everything it's becoming very
difficult for us to manage as a couple
the front-runner liz trust is promising
action on the cost of living crisis
within the first week and speaking to
people here in bristol it is the single
most important issue that needs dealing
with not just for households but
businesses as well want help and quickly
at arisha's dessert cafe in bristol
they've had no choice but to put up
prices
from the new prime minister we are
expecting everything is really expensive
the light electricity water everything
we are paying double uh we lost like 50
percent customer because like the prices
are really high the they get angry they
say like they are really angry when they
see the prices like we increased the
prices like two three months ago
and they they get very angry about it
right
angry customers are the last thing at a
needs but like everyone in this city is
facing higher prices
the question is how to ease this
situation
millions across this country will be
looking to the new pm
for the answer
dan white said sky news in bristol